hi there
day 11 i guess day 12 mindy didn't get
as much done today as i would have liked
although um
there's still time
i played two hockey games today in our
old timers tournament so most of my
korean learning today consisted of
driving out to coquitlam which is 35
minutes away driving back driving out
there again and driving back
so
that's a fair amount it's 140
minutes of listening 35 and 35 to 70 145
minutes of listening not all of which i
understand
it's this
kim jong-bay
uh but on his website uh he he's a
podcaster uh discusses news every day
and on his website there are transcripts
which i discovered yesterday so i don't
have to pay for transcripts i just
grabbed his transcripts got his audio
bring it in the link and away i go so i
listened to a lot of it didn't
understand much and i have to go through
it now linking and see what i can learn
but just to show you a bit of the scene
here in vancouver i'm gonna add on some
videos of me arriving at the parking lot
uh where we play the game and it's a
shot of the guys in the dressing room
just before we went out to play we won
this morning 4-1 we tied one all this
afternoon although we out shot the other
team 31-6 or something anyway
that's it bye for now
okay so i i'm in this uh over 70s hockey
tournament i guess you can't
you can just make out the rink in the
background but of course that means that
you just see my
face in the shade
and it's in kokwitlam and nearby here
was a korean bookstore
so
i went there and bought a book i didn't
have my camera with me so i can't show
you i talked about two books
but i'll show you one of the books here
if i can figure out how i reverse this
image here
that's not the right thing so i'll stop
it so here you see the one of the korean
books that i bought uh
and now i have to go and get my stuff
out of my trunk here and go into the
dressing room and get ready to play the
second game we played this morning at 8
15 and we're playing again now at 3 45.
i don't know why i do this at my age
maybe i'll take some shots take a video
of the guys in the dressing room so it's
the famous old goats we're being allowed
into the famous old ghost dressing room
before a vital game in this apartment
and that sweater belongs to a
stellar defenseman john davidson
and we have a number of stellar goats
all around this room you were there and
john and pam of course
struggling with
now my role on this team is that i
always forget stuff steal other people's
stuff
so the main thing for me today is not to
take not to leave my skate guards on
when i step on the ice something that i
have done twice